last night the remaining Democratic
candidates for president faced off to
debate climate change in a seven hour
long townhall that released so much hot
air into the atmosphere that climate
change is now real and we're all going
to die from it we will examine the
winners the losers and the most
disturbing answers of the night then
speaking of climate change it must be a
chilly day in hell because the White
House has received good news from the
New York Times Walmart bans guns from
its stores and finally the mailbag I am
Michael Knowles and this is the Michael
Knowles show
[Music]
seven hours of climate change seven
hours of listening to Democratic
candidates talk about climate change is
much worse than any possible effect of
climate change including the end of the
world mass starvation mass environmental
kids it doesn't hold a candle to
watching CNN and the Democrats for seven
hours this was a very very bad night for
the Democratic Party so let's jump right
in because we have a lot of ground to
cover let's start with the most radical
answer of the night when Bernie Sanders
the oldest candidate I think in the
history of all of politics Bernie
Sanders endorsed eugenics to combat
climate change human population growth
has more than doubled in the past 50
years the planet cannot sustain this
growth I realize this is a poisonous
topic for politicians but it's crucial
to face empowering women and educating
everyone on the need to curb population
growth seems a reasonable campaign to
enact would you be courageous enough to
discuss this issue and make it a key
feature of a plan to address climate
catastrophe well the answer is yes so he
gives the answer yes right away craziest
question of the night of course and also
this brings up a question for law
enforcement who let this member of the
Manson family run away from prison and
ask a question at a CNN Town Hall I mean
the voice the look the topic that she's
bringing up is sociopathic it is
something out of the nightmare of the
late 60s and early 70s it is like helter
skelter on CNN so so creepy she's saying
there are too many people there's a
problem no too many people
overpopulation with the climate it's
harming Mother Earth so we gotta kill
all the people don't we now you notice
what's so interesting about this if she
really thinks there are too many people
on earth why doesn't she do something
about it you know it's always suggest we
kill babies or we kill the the elderly
or we kill the sick the people who say
we
overpopulation never look at themselves
as the cause of the overpopulation I
think G K Chesterton mention this it's
never like me I could no no it's just
those vulnerable people the little
babies and the sick and the elderly
those are the ones we have to kill off
but not me I'm not causing the
overpopulation first even before you get
to Bernie's real answer look at how the
terminology has evolved we talk a lot
about political correctness how if you
control the words you control the
culture because you you basically
smuggle in whole premises with the
language that you use so we went from in
the 1970s the environmental problem was
global cooling that was the term they
used then in the 80s and 90s it became
global warming then in the early 2000s
it became climate change then just a
couple years ago it became the climate
crisis it's really speeding up now
tonight is this woman is talking it
becomes the climate catastrophe what is
the catastrophe there are weather events
I mean weather events had tornadoes
hurricanes tsunamis but that happened
forever for all of human history what
about right now is catastrophic
nothing's happening it's all fine right
it's not it's not a catastrophe it's not
crisis you guys you can say the climate
is changing is the climate always
changes it's not really getting warmer
depends on what time period you're
looking at and what measures you're
looking at it's not really getting
cooler again depends on what what time
periods and measurements you're looking
at but it becomes catastrophe and we're
all supposed to by that premise then she
gets to the question itself which is are
you willing to sacrifice children to
appease the weather gods that's the
question right the question she's asking
that she is implying is should we
control the population that's the
euphemism should we encourage abortion
should we encourage killing babies to
stop bad weather events from happening
this is exactly the same as in any pagan
religion when you sacrifice babies to
the weather gods there is no difference
whatsoever except the scale here in this
case is a little bit larger
what is Bernie's answer he immediately
comes out he says yes here's the rest of
him would you be courageous enough to
discuss this issue and make it a key
feature of a plan to address climate
catastrophe well the answer is yes and
the answer has everything to do with the
fact that women in the United States of
America by the way have a right to
control their own bodies and make
decisions and the Mexico City agreement
which denies American aid to those
organizations around the world that are
that allow women to have abortions or
even get involved in birth control to me
is totally absurd so what's so amazing
about this answer from Bernie Sanders is
how he goes right for it he just goes
right for the abortion question a
sensible politician a more rational or
moderate politician would have deftly
one hopes evaded this insane lady's
bonkers question by pretending that
she's talking about contraception or
birth control rather than about abortion
itself right so he could have said yes
well we need sex education in schools we
need to make sure that people are and
having children that they can't take
care of or some right that that could
have been the direction that he went in
but he doesn't he just goes straight for
abortion on its own terms and he doesn't
even just stop at abortion in the United
States he says that we need to export
abortion promote abortion pay for
abortions all over the world so we're
not even content to kill a million of
our own babies a year we got to go out
and pay to kill the babies of people all
around the world to appease the climate
gods so that we have a good harvest or
something when conservatives point out
that the Democratic Party has embraced
eugenics remember this moment we'll get
into this and we'll get into even the
worst night the worst performance of the
night was not even Joe Biden there was
not even Bernie Sanders rather it was
Joe Biden Bernie Sanders embraces
eugenics to appease the weather guts
somehow Biden still had a worse night
than that we'll get to it in a second
but first we'll talk about an actual
problem which is credit card debt credit
card debt is a very serious problem that
a lot of people struggle
because it's just so easy you got that
little piece of plastic you go and you
can put anything on it you can buy a car
on a credit card these days and what you
forget or what you ignore when you do
that or those high interest rates that
you are paying you know you've got this
buy it now pay for it later kind of
mentality that's how credit card
companies rope everybody in and they
leave out the part about paying later
with interest not just interest high
interest thanks to Lending Club you can
consolidate your debt or pay off credit
cards with one fixed monthly payment
Lending Club has helped millions of
people regain control of their finances
with affordable fixed-rate personal
loans that means no trips to the bank
very important for me as a millennial
because I don't want to leave my chair
no high interest credit cards you just
go to Lending Club calm you tell them
about yourself how much you want to
borrow you pick the terms that are right
for you if you are approved your loan is
automatically deposited into your bank
account in as little as a few days let
really really good technology work for
you I know people can be a little lazy
about these things so I'll just keep it
on the credit card it's no big deal it
is a big deal you're losing money
needlessly Lending Club is the number
one peer-to-peer lending platform over
thirty five billion dollars in loans
issued go to Lending Club com slash note
scanner wles check your write minutes
borrow up to forty thousand dollars that
is Lending Club comm slash Knolls kuna
wles Lending Club comm slash Knolls
all loans made by webb bank member FDIC
Equal Housing lender now back to the
horrific solutions to imaginary problems
at the Democratic Climate Change Town
Hall when conservatives point out that
the Democratic Party has embraced
eugenics this is the moment that you
need to remember Bernie Sanders is not
just some random person on Twitter
Bernie Sanders is not just some fringe
guy Bernie Sanders is the number two
leading Democratic candidate for
president and by the way he was the
number two Democratic candidate for
president last time around too this is a
major political figure this is a major
leader in the Democratic Party and he is
saying that we need to sacrifice our
children to appease the weather gods
well it's but not our children
your children he's not gonna do it to
his own children but he wants to do it
to your children or disproportionately
black children because black women have
much much higher rates of abortion in
the United States and this is encouraged
by abortion hustlers like Planned
Parenthood and as you can see by the
Democratic Party this is I cannot stress
it enough no different from what the
Aztecs did when the Aztecs would
slaughter
scores of people you know in 1487 five
years before Columbus sailed across the
ocean
the Aztecs slaughtered an estimated
80,000 people men women and children at
the consecration of the temple of
Tenochtitlan and actually you know there
is a little bit of a difference between
what we do and what the Aztecs do the
Aztecs sacrificed all those people to
appease their gods their pagan gods
we're sacrificing way way way more way
way way more innocent people every
single year we're sacrificing a million
babies a year in this country killing
them to appease a number of false gods
credentialism you're in college and you
don't want to have a kid but you're
pregnant so you kill it your career
you're not ready to have a kid right now
your personal freedom you want to go out
and go be able to go to the bar more
often not be responsible to a kid we
sacrifice our children to plenty of
false gods and in this case we are being
encouraged by leading Democratic
presidential candidates to sacrifice our
own babies in this country and abroad to
the weather gods so that I don't know
the rains will come and we can yield a
good harvest this year that's the kind
of stuff that we are seeing here and
even with that absolute lunacy Bernie
did not have the worst night joe biden
did joe biden was the biggest loser of
the night at this town hall why a couple
reasons to begin it you can't ignore it
he did say crazy things not maybe not
quite as crazy as Bernie though I mean
they weren't they weren't as evil as
Bernie there weren't as evil as
sacrificing your children to the weather
gods but they were as crazy Joe Biden at
one point in the in the town hall blamed
cancer and the Darfur genocide on
climate change and so where are we look
what happened in darf
for what star for all about Darfur is
all about the fact that the sub-saharan
does it because of the change in climate
no longer had enough area Boland
look what's happening in Tunisia they're
talking about moving their capital
because it's gonna sink what happens if
you get ten twelve thirteen fifteen
hundred million people on the move that
causes Wars and so it's well beyond
whether or not it affects me personally
which it does and it did my family and
still does
just like your families this is personal
it's personally every one of you
probably have a story that can talk
about what's happened to something you
care greatly about whether it's a
species or at your son or daughter
coming down with cancer because of it
coming down with cancer because of
climate change because of what what are
you talking about has nothing to do with
anything and then genocide is because of
climate change amazing how he ignores
the political he ignores the cultural he
ignores all of human agency all of the
choices that people make when they kill
one another and he blames it on the sky
gods on the weather gods I mean this
this theme that we see recurring is not
just coincidental it's not just
accidental it is a sort of fatalism that
denies human agency which means it
denies human freedom and this is a
through-line from the left this is a
through-line from the democratic party
it's not even just on this one
particular issue you see a cropping up
all over the place the left increasingly
denies our humanity our human dignity
denies our you know no human dignity
obviously by slaughtering all of these
people it denies our freedom it denies
our free will it says we're just matter
we're just stuff we're all just clumps
of cells and we are moved along by
impersonal forces outside of ourselves
it's a real sort of fatalism genocides
including the genocide in Darfur were
caused by people choosing to commit
genocides by governments choosing to do
that you know this language this this
religious kind of language is exactly
what we were talking about yesterday
climate change is not about science
it's about religion and it is
specifically about a false religion it
actually shows us this this issue of
climate change we think of this is a
very modern issue brought about by
science actually this is the oldest most
primitive issue in the world in all of
politics and it has nothing to do with
science we'll get to that in one second
but first I've got to thank our friends
over at wise foods because if you
actually have an emergency I'm not
talking about the imaginary emergency as
the politicians try to sell us but a
real emergency you need to be prepared
wise foods can help you they're the best
ones to help you wise company takes an
innovative approach in providing
dependable simple and affordable
freeze-dried food for emergency
preparedness and outdoor use when
government resources are strained it can
take days if not weeks before you can
get to fresh food and water and you
can't rely on someone else and if you
watch that town hall last night you'd
definitely know you can't rely on any of
those people you can't rely on the
government you have to rely on yourself
you don't know what tomorrow may bring
but you can't have peace of mind knowing
that you will be ready for it you know
the thing I really like about wise foods
is not even that it's it's an excellent
product which it is it is a top-tier
top-shelf product the thing I like best
about it is it just gives me peace of
mind I don't need to worry I don't need
to have this constant simmering stress
of what am I gonna do if something goes
wrong we got to get out of Dodge we
don't have access to food or water don't
put yourself in a situation where you
need something that you don't have get
prepared today wherever you live an
emergency can strike whether that's a
weather emergency it's a hurricane
that's a tornado it's a wildfire it's
where I live you know in LA it's an
earthquake anywhere you live an
emergency can strike it could be a
political emergency it could be an
attack be prepared it just have peace of
mind this week my listeners can get any
wise emergency arrived or food product
and an extra 25 percent off the lowest
marked price you can only get that at
wise food storage calm and enter Knowles
canner wles at checkout or you can call
eight five five four five three two nine
four five shipping is free Wise has a 90
day no questions asked return policy no
risk and taking the initiative to get
yourself and your family more prepared
today wise food storage calm promo code
Knowles kena wles get any wise emergency
or at door food
product at an extra 25% off and free
shipping this climate change issue the
way that they're talking about it
sacrificing their children that climate
change is causing genocides the climate
change is causing cancer that the way
they're talking about it is not modern
and it's not scientific this is ancient
this is primitive this goes back to our
most pagan roots and it tries to explain
religious questions without true
religion what Joe Biden is doing is he's
using climate change to try to answer
the eternal question that has bothered
mankind as long as we've been conscious
which is why is there suffering in the
world why is there pain why do bad
things happen to good people and the
traditional answer the quill I say
traditional let me be more specific
the Christian answer the Jewish answer
the Muslim answer is that man disobeyed
God and so sin entered the world and so
with sin death pervaded the world there
is a fall of man we were kicked out of
paradise and that fall of man pervades
the whole world now the secular left
which doesn't believe in true religion
has updated this view for a world
without God so sin and death enter the
world not because we disobeyed God but
because we disobeyed mother earth
because we disobeyed Gaia which is a
term for nature by polluting not that we
disobeyed and we ate the apple from the
tree I guess we it might be because of
our interactions with trees but it's
because we polluted so in the religious
view in the view of true religion we
cannot save ourselves we cannot
reconcile ourselves to God instead we
need a savior in the modern secular view
we can save ourselves we can do it and
the way we do it is not even by moral
improvement or by living out the virtues
it's by recycling it's by not fracking
it's by killing our babies in many ways
it's the opposite of the virtues and
here we see how this view this new
religious view what the left would call
its kind of new metaphysical view its
new way to answer this eternal
question is not modern after all it's
not new it's just the pagan view we
sacrifice people you know I mean it's
like actually the pagan view we
sacrifice people even blood sacrifices
even sacrifices of our children to
appease the gods and save ourselves even
beyond Joe Biden listen to the way that
who Leon Castro who by the way he's
still in the race I don't know if you
knew that I don't know if you ever knew
that he was in the race but he was the
former HUD secretary and for some reason
he's still in the race for president
here is who leon castro talking about
how we need to get climate change
ideology into schools really really
young we have to teach kids he's not
speaking in academic or scientific terms
he's speaking in religious terms and
he's speaking with greater zeal than any
advocate of teaching the bible in school
that I've ever heard give a listen our
beliefs and habits start in an early age
she climate change be taught in schools
and if so how should climate education
be implemented in the school curriculum
yes I believe that it should in fact I
believe that it's essential if we want
to raise the generations a generation of
Americans that will you know do right by
our planet make the little decisions in
life
that are gonna help ensure that we can
get where we need to get to get to Net
Zero listen to those phrases do right by
our planet get where we need to get make
the right decisions in life how do you
do right by the planet the planets Iraq
the planet is a rock that has some
animals and trees on you mean do right
by the planet we are moral creatures
human beings we have the capacity to
reason that's what separates us from the
brutes and from the animals in the rocks
what does it mean to do right by the
planet he's speaking in religious terms
and Biden is buying into this too
because he knows the only way that he's
going to get through this primary is by
running to the left so now he runs so
far the left he is asked about the green
New Deal 93 trillion dollars a
ridiculous pie-in-the-sky plan that
would be horrific if it were enacted and
that doesn't even really address the
climate or the environment in any way he
is now saying the green new deal doesn't
go too far in your plan used
the green New Deal is quote a crucial
framework for meeting the climate
challenges we face you say it has two
basic truths that we need to combat the
climate crisis with what you say is
ambition on an epic scale and that the
environment and economy are in your
words completely and totally connected
you're not saying that you support
everything in the original green New
Deal do you think it goes too far is it
unrealistic promising too much it's not
here here's what it is it doesn't have a
lot of specifics it doesn't have a lot
of specifics about exactly what we'll do
with regard to greenhouse gases okay
fair enough it doesn't have a lot of
specifics but he says it doesn't go too
far I mean these are pretty wacky
answers and Biden had the worst night
not just because of what he said not
just because of these wacky answers but
more importantly because of how he said
it he just seems too old here's just one
little quick example of Joe Biden
stammering incoherently for 10 or 15
seconds look what's happened in the
Midwest we have a number of significant
bases that Renee's relate military bases
that relate to our national security
that in fact were rendered almost
useless including I can't go into the
great detail to say but my point is it
it's significantly reduced our national
security
I I want to bring up an example but I
can't I'm not gonna bring it up but I
and what was the question again could
you get to the question and then things
really went downhill from there when Joe
Biden's
eyeball appeared to explode we'll get to
that in just one second I don't mean to
laugh at it he's he's fine he seems to
be doing okay but it is in fact the case
that the Democratic frontrunner iBall
appeared to explode on stage we'll get
to that in one second first most
importantly if you have bought a
timeshare you know the pitch oh it's a
great investment you can stay whenever
you want wherever you want it's so great
come on just give us your money it'll be
great you'll get it's like you'll be on
vacation all the time well guess what
none of that is true the ugly truth is
that with a timeshare you can never tell
how much it's really going to cost you
can never tell when it's going to end
many owners are trying to sell their
time shares online and they find out the
hard way is none
an investment when you can't get a
dollar for it and with those rising
annual maintenance and assessment fees
buying a timeshare is like giving the
timeshare company a blank check for life
even when you die your family gets stuck
with this burden so stop the insanity
today there is a way out if you were
stuck in a timeshare nightmare I have a
couple relatives who made this mistake
it is so important to go use the best to
get out of this these time shoes it's
really hard go go to I cancel timeshare
com
tell them that I sent you Wesley
Financial Group guarantees they will
legally get you out of your timeshare
contract permanently or you pay nothing
it can be very difficult to get out of
these timeshares Wesley financial route
makes it as easy as it gets get your
free information kit telling you all
about how it works go to I cancel
timeshare com
that is I cancel timeshare dot-com so
Biden's performance really went downhill
not with the wacky answers but when his
eyeball appeared to explode so here's a
question from a kid who says he's an ex
Republican now he's asking him a
question about climate change and Joe
Biden's eyeball just starts to fill with
blood China is currently the largest
emitter of co2 how if at all would you
try to get China to lower its emissions
as president I would make it real clear
that's why we have to bring around the
rest of the world we have to reconfigure
ok UK he goes on if you haven't seen the
clip or you can't see it go check it out
online actually it's a pretty good
question you know leave it to the ex
Republican to ask the one normal
question of the entire night but the
question didn't matter cuz no one
listened to the answer because everyone
was looking at the blood pooling in Joe
Biden's eye he had something called a
sub conjunctival hemorrhage that's when
the blood blood vessels explode in your
eyeball and it fills with blood the man
is simply too old he's too old to be
President he's not look we've Reagan was
a fairly elderly president by
presidential standards Trump not exactly
a spring chicken those guys looked young
they acted young they had a lot of
energy Biden has had health problems for
years in the 80s Biden had two brain
aneurysms that he suffered they didn't
pop fortunately if you've ever
experienced
brain aneurysm in a family-type way I
have up close I mean that is a serious
serious problem usually leads to death
if it is caught before it bursts at you
know one it can still burst and leave
you dead or can leave you mentally
impaired luckily Biden's survived that
in the 80s but he's had major health
scares like this since the 80s and it
kind of reminds me of Dick Cheney you
know Dick Cheney had his first heart
attack in like 1978 or something does
anybody believe that Dick Cheney is up
for being president of the United States
no nobody did he what Cheney could do is
be the vice president to a younger
president so he kind of has the elderly
statesman role the elder statesman role
and also a little bit elderly Joe Biden
more or less filled that role for Barack
Obama the younger president but no one
really believes that this guy's fit
enough to be President and then by not
just Biden but other candidates too
demonstrated my favorite aspect of it of
the whole debate which was the rank
hypocrisy of the whole thing you know
Biden by Anderson Cooper gets called out
for preaching climate change on one one
night you know how urgent it is how we
need to stop it and then attending a
fossil-fuel fundraiser the next night
there is a fundraiser tomorrow night
it's given by a guy named Andrew Goldman
he's a he does hedge funds and stuff but
he also has a company called Western LNG
and their biggest project which I think
was announced in like 2018 is a floating
liquefied facility for natural gas
that's off the coast of British Columbia
and it's going to provide Canadian gas
to parts of northern Asia so what andrew
is saying is if you're going to a
fundraiser that's given in part by this
guy who has a company that is pulling up
natural gas are you the right guy to go
after this well I didn't realize he does
that classic Biden answer I mean I
assume Biden doesn't really care getting
money from the fossil fuel industry but
in his defense he is losing his marbles
and he may well have not realized that
the guy does that another area you see
this hypocrisy last night is not just
the kind of would be moderate Joe it's
even in one of the most openly radical
candidates who Leon Castro he gets
called out for
changing his mind on climate change when
it suits him ports warned that we only
have 11 years to get off fossil fuels to
have a safe livable future but as mayor
of San Antonio you welcome the fracking
boom why should we trust you as
president to transition our economy to
renewables given your past middle ground
approach I appreciate the question from
Silla and you know I want to commend the
sunrise movement as you know they've
been pushing for a democratic climate
debate which I hope happens I'm glad
that we're having this we're having this
conversation today so first of all she's
right when I was mayor of San Antonio I
did believe that there were
opportunities to be had in fracking that
was going on in South Texas the thing is
that back then which was you know almost
a decade ago we had been saying that
natural gas was a bridge fuel right
we're coming to the end of the bridge
yeah okay buddy you said it because it
was convenient because you wanted the
jobs and you wanted the money because it
was helpful to you then and now it's not
helpful to you so you're trying to come
up with a bogus answer when candidates
thank someone for a question and then
spend like 20 seconds talking about how
important it is to have that question in
this conversation you know that they got
nothing they ran out so total hypocrisy
that's fine we mean this like Prince
Harry you know Prince Harry's on one day
he says climate change is the most
important issue in the world no one can
go on vacation anymore and then you look
and he flies on a private jet four times
in 11 days it's just bogus people don't
believe it but they're hypocritically
paying lip service to their false
religion the funniest moment of the
night came from Cory Booker you forgot
he was in the debate me too you forgot
that he's running for president
me too but here is the single funniest
moment of the night when Cory Booker
said that he will be President so my
plan says that we need to be are at a
zero carbon electric electricity by 2030
that's that's ten years from the time
that I will win the presidency of the
United States of America
oh it's ten years from February 31st
2000 Kay well then I'm not too worried
about those 10 yrs there was another
hilarious moment of the night when it
came to plastic straws we'll get to the
big winner of the night not just the big
loser which was Joe Biden but the big
winner then we'll get to quickly the New
York Times and Walmart then the mailbag
but first I gotta say goodbye to
Facebook and YouTube go to daily wire
com 10 bucks a month $100 for annual
membership you get everything you get it
every you know what you get you get
everything plus you get the leftist ears
tumblr you need it for that 7th hour of
the climate catastrophe catastrophe you
need that tumblr otherwise you're gonna
drown from another climate catastrophe
go to daily wire com we'll be right back
second funniest moment of the entire
debate I have to just get to Kamala
Harris because Kamala Harris said she
finally addressed the central climate
issue forget fossil fuels forget
sacrificing her babies to the weather
gods
the central issue the plastic straws she
said we need to ban the plastic straws
she then admitted the paper straws are
terrible
she then laughed nervously which is her
tell when you can tell she doesn't want
to answer a question do you ban plastic
straws we should yes I mean look I'm
gonna be honest it's really difficult to
drink out of a paper straw when you had
if you're just like if you don't gulp it
down immediately it starts to bend and
then you know the little thing catches
it and then you know but so we got a
kind of perfect
don't make me fleece I don't know what
I'm supposed to think really bad she's
such a bad candidate she could have been
so good but she's just really bad on
stage so funny though her aunt would you
ban plastic straws yeah sure doesn't
explain why by the way people don't know
this the whole plastic straw thing was
started by a nine-year-old boy named
Milo kress in 2011 who came up with a
completely baseless evidence list bogus
number that the u.s. uses 500 million
plastic straws a day and then the way he
found that number was he just called a
few companies and tried to put a number
together like for a fourth grade report
and then he put this out there and now
leading Democratic candidates for
president or touting it and we're now
not allowed to use our plastic straws we
now need to use those sippy cups which
use more plastic which is almost
certainly just as bad if not worse for
the environment neither here nor there
big winner of the night Liz Warren I
didn't show any clips from her why
because she played it safe this is a big
loser issue for the Democratic Party the
Democrats should not have agreed to this
Town Hall climate change is a bad issue
for them nationwide it's good with their
most fervent supporters it makes them
look like absolute lunatics to the rest
of the country to the soft left to the
center and obviously to the right Liz
Warren knew that going in she's a really
clever candidate she played it really
safe so she doesn't get any of these
pull outs stupid moments even more bad
news for Democrats
who were I guess overall the Democratic
Party is that probably the big loser and
and Joe Biden as the face of it more bad
news for Democrats were not heading for
a recession according to an economist in
The New York Times
it's very quickly I guess it's a chilly
day in hell on that climate change
headline a recession is not inevitable
the case for economic optimism they they
show in the New York Times they're
worried some leading indicators on the
economy are real but so are the sources
of resilience that could keep the
expansion going and the guy concludes
there are a lot of risks out there and
it makes sense for CEOs and ordinary
consumers to be wary of what the future
could hold but for now a gloomy economic
future remains a far from certain
possibility very important news for
Trump he just in the last few days
getting funding for the border wall has
just shored up a major vulnerability the
other major vulnerability is the economy
if even the New York Times is admitting
that we're not necessarily heading for a
recession they're trying to tamp down
expectations for a recession great news
for the White House other crazy news we
just have to get to it quickly
Walmart is now banning gun spanning the
sale of guns the sale of ammo and
they're discouraging customers from
bringing guns into their own stores to
protect themselves Walmart is a massive
massive corporation such an American
company Sam Walton creates Wal Mart good
old American dies in 1992 I believe the
reason I bring up this story is not to
show anything about Walmart I don't care
about Walmart it's to show that in just
a generation after the death of the
founder Walmart has so dramatically
changed that it is unrecognizable Sam
Walton is probably turning over in his
grave the second amendment is the Second
Amendment you know it's pretty important
it's right there in the Constitution and
even Walmart that most of American of
stores is now ditching it because of
public pressure from the left it just
shows you how fragile institutions can
be how good the left is it going in and
hollowing out institutions how little
protection there is for them we need to
be careful of that and when we look as
we've been looking at the 2020
presidential election we need to be very
protective of those institutions of our
government which can change on a dime
and and increasingly can change
radically let's
the mailbag very quickly we're in a fly
through first question from Richard
Michael president Trump was elected to
expose the media bias he was also
elected to expose the squishy
Republicans who do you think would be
the best Republican candidate to
maintain that level of confidence in
2024 look Trump was elected for a lot of
reasons two of which are as you say it's
simply too early to predict who the
candidate will be in 2024 if you had
asked five years out in 2016 you know in
2011 who the candidate would be no one
would have said Trump even the hardcore
conservatives were pretty skeptical of
Trump because he donated to Democrats
and espoused democratic views left-wing
views for a lot of his life so just to
use a recent example that was floated in
the media it was floated across a few
articles that Tucker Carlson could run
for president I'm not saying that's a
good idea I'm not saying it's a bad idea
I'm saying that would be the sort of
candidacy that you would expect in a
post Trump world where you no longer
need to have held political office for
your whole life where you can be a
little more hardcore where you don't
need to be conciliatory and go to all
the fancy lunches and be friends with
Democrats all at the time you could see
something like that happening you could
see Kanye West running for president I'm
not saying that's a definitely not
saying that's a great idea but you could
see that sort of thing happening and I
think what is important whoever the
candidate is is that we not by the lie
of the Left win in the squishes that the
candidate needs to have gone to exactly
the right schools gone to the right law
school then worked on the hill or
something then been a fellow at a
think-tank and then you know speak
really nicely about everybody and be
really moderate and conciliatory you use
the example of Marco Rubio all the smart
class whether it was cable news or the
kind of coastal media types who are
conservatives thought that Marco Rubio
was the great candidate in 2016 when you
looked at election analysis the only
people who liked Marco Rubio for
president were conservatives and
Republicans who live in left-wing places
but that's a losing strategy
doesn't matter what those guys vote for
because the their votes are gonna go
through the electoral college to the
Democrat we need to stop falling into
that trap and I suspect that in the post
trump future whoever the candidate is I
don't I don't think we have any idea
what that name is going to be yet it's
gonna have to be a candidate that bucks
that party establishment that bucks all
of the false niceness and false
politeness in the way that in in recent
memory - only two candidates have done
Ronald Reagan and Donald Trump from
Brian Michael I'm 32 with a 7 year old
daughter I was not raised with any
religion but over the years I've begun
to understand the importance of religion
and community we want to begin to
practice religion but where do we start
feel strange to just Google a religion
it were drop in on a local church and
say we chose this one do you have any
advice yeah you know where I ended up I
mean I was an atheist for about 10 years
and then I was convinced of the
existence of God in part because of a
Calvinist philosopher named Alvin
Plantinga I was friends with many many
Orthodox Jews and would go to a lot of
Shabbat dinners I read the Quran I think
at age 14 mostly because I suspected it
was being misrepresented in the
mainstream media and then I ended up now
as a Catholic I returned to the Catholic
Church at 23 24 and I you know now it
attend a Latin Mass and pretty into it
pretty into practicing Catholicism so
I've run the gamut and you know where I
landed I landed on the Catholic Church
so of course I would suggest that you
might begin by reading CS Lewis's mere
christianity this is a really good
introductory apologetics book I would
recommend if you are going to try out
different churches or try on different
aspects of religion go figure out the
differences you know if you conclude
that God exists which is the correct
conclusion then you have to grapple with
the person of Christ is Christ who he
says he is if he is
then you get to the next question what
is the nature of his church this is a
question that was uniform for the first
atleast thousand years of Christianity
there were different heresies that would
pop up the Arian heresy the Marcion
heresy various aspects which were
rejected by the church figure out why
the church rejected those heresies then
you get to the question of the great
schism between the East and the West
which wasn't really theological so you
don't need to grapple with that as much
then five hundred years later you get to
the the Protestant revolution and so you
can examine those arguments and then you
can examine the arguments against those
arguments I've gone through all of that
and again you know how I landed but I
think that's the order that you've got
to progress in in the meantime as you're
grappling with that those intellectual
questions and those questions of their
constitution of the church you need to
pray you need to behave as though God
exists and you should find a church and
if your views change then I guess you
can change your church but the most
important thing is don't just keep it in
your head don't just stew on it in the
abstract you got to do it for Mitchell
Michael I teach in a public Middle
School and there is a poster in our
teachers lounge that explains how gender
and biological sex are completely
distinct from each other and are not
connected in any way I've also been told
that I need to call one of my students
by male pronouns when she is a girl and
I disagree with this message how do I
address this in a public work setting
what are some tips for supporting my
argument thanks love the show well I'm
curious to see what that poster would
say about how sex and gender are
completely different and not connected
at all I suspect it just asserts that
without actually giving any argument for
it because there is no argument for it
it's merely an assertion the whole
concept of gender as being applied to
human beings is a very new concept and
it was really only popularized during
the rise of post-modernism gender is a
grammatical concept it rely it refers to
the nature of words so they're masculine
words and feminine words you know in
Italian a good rule is where that ends
in a is feminine like pizza la pizza and
a word that ends
oh is is masculine so like canola like
cannoli
that's masculine that doesn't refer to
people now the gender was applied to
refer to people as separate from sex
specifically because of an ideological
agenda to separate sex from gender but
that is simply an assertion that is an
assertion of the will that is not a
reasonable argument now if you were
being told to refer to up is down or
black as white or a woman as a man or a
man as a woman I couldn't do that I
would not do that if you don't do that
you might lose your job that's how far
we are into this coercive gender
ideology that's a decision for you to
make you know what I would do but I'm in
a different line of work and I'm
imparted in a different line of work
because I refuse to make those decisions
I would always ask questions if you want
really want to change mine so I'd say
ask somebody hey how is it the gender
and sex are different say well they're
because gender refers to your identity
and sex refers to your biology say oh
okay alright so if gender is just kind
of your identity then it's just like how
you feel right I'll say no I actually
had this debate with someone at a an
event in Michigan say no no it's not
just how you feel it's how you identify
you know you know some people are women
born in men's bodies say okay well if
they're born that way then it's
biological - right then gender is
biological the same no no no gender is
how you identify sex is your biology
okay well then where is this identity
where is the if really how can you prove
to me that you're a woman in a man's
body and one of the arguments they bring
up which is not scientific but it's
become a sort of top science term is a
pop pop science notion is that really if
you examine the brains of men and women
and transgender men and women that
they're very different and the brains of
men who identify as women are closer to
women and the brains of women who
identify as men or closer to men again
that's so much of this is is a
mealy-mouthed language because the Brent
the brains of men and women just aren't
that different to begin with and this is
based on very small sample
sizes to even suggest this and even if
it were what would that mean am I simply
my brain or am i more of my body what is
my identity but even just take them on
the premises say ok so their brains are
women's brains but their bodies are
men's bodies so then you are saying
gender is biological not merely
emotional or psychological then you are
saying that that distinction you made
between sex and gender doesn't really
exist the hard distinction between how
you identify in your biology and they're
going to get confused by this and then
they might realize that the whole
separation of sex and gender is a
distinction without a difference try to
get to one more from Leeanne dear
Michael podcaster giant and philosopher
Wow
what a title thank you growing up in my
time there were women who stayed home
with their kids full-time and today the
children are all in daycare because more
women are working I've been told if I'm
a stay-at-home housewife or a
stay-at-home mom that I'm not fulfilling
my potential how did this change and why
well this changed in part because of
world war ii when women started to enter
the workforce this changed in part
because of the women's lib movement
which then became known as second wave
feminism this this changed in part
because the more honest feminists over
the past 50 years have said not merely
that women should have the choice to
work or to stay at home the more honest
feminists have said women can I think
was Gloria Steinem but I could be
getting that wrong it was one of the
very prominent feminists of the last 50
years said if women have the choice to
stay at home and too many of them will
and this will compromise other woman's
ability to go into the workforce so you
you actually have to discourage the
choice to stay at home I mean what is
your potential depends some women thrive
in professional environments and some
women thrive at home some women sort of
can do both you can't have it all but
you can do two things at once
so what is your potential I mean if the
potential is you can be a loving
housewife and have a beautiful family
and have take care of your husband and
be involved in your community and be
involved in your church and all those
things that seems like rather fulfilled
potential and if the alternative is that
you're a middle manager at the widget
Factory and you make a lot of widgets
and then you die and your husband is on
his own and if you have kids you know
the kids don't get taken care of or they
go to some daycare I don't that doesn't
seem like fulfilled potential it changed
because of coercion and it changed
because of the lies of feminism which
said that men and women are exactly the
same but also men and women are
completely different and but also that
now now that we're back at the gender
ideology that men and women are exactly
the same again I mean it's a it's an
incoherent ideology based merely on the
will part of that will was coercing
women into not being able to stay at
home anymore and having to go to the
widget Factory but if you don't want to
go to the widget Factory then you stay
home you'll be a housewife you'll have a
great life worked worked very well for a
long time for a lot of women that's our
show come back on Monday we'll have a
whole lot more
in the meantime I'm Michael Knowles this
is the Michael Nolt show see you then
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
Rebecca dobkins director Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring our
senior producer is Jonathan hey
supervising producer
Mathis Glover technical producer Austin
Stephens editor Danny D'Amico our audio
mixer is Mike Cora Meena hair and makeup
by Jesuit Elvira production assistant
Nick Sheehan the Michael Nolt show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 19 if you prefer facts over
feelings if you aren't offended by the
brutal truth if you can still laugh at
the nuttiness filling our national news
cycle well tune on into the Ben Shapiro
show or you'll get a whole lot of that
and much more we'll see you there